The United States right now.
I don't believe I haven't looked at those figures in a while,
but I don't think that the United States is the largest polluter in the world.
I think that China and India are above us. Now,
here you have four and a half billion people, um,
who are trying to get rich quick and who are spewing a lot of CO2 into the
atmosphere and who are also very competitive with us because they have very low
wages. So to tie ourselves to the Paris climate accord,
uh, was the wrong way to go about it. And you know,
what else happened was that the United States has decreased its
emissions of CO2 per capita at a faster pace than most places in the
world. Why? Because we started, uh,
we started getting rid of our coal power plants and we started introducing more
and more natural gas into our electricity production and natural gas
burns, or rather emits much less CO2 than coal.
And so by simply by innovating,
by basically changing the source of fuel from coal to natural gas,
we were able to decrease our CO2 emissions at a faster click than we would have
been obliged to do under Paris.
Yeah.
One of the interesting things about, uh,
this trend I thought was that your answer basically said sort of trust that
human ideas can solve problems.
And that in many ways is so counter to what we hear coming out of the left. Now,
you know, we hear about the, the green new deal and that,
that this centralized planning thing can somehow magically just
sort of solve all of these problems if we just gave it enough power, but it,
but in many ways, you're what power and money, of course. But in many ways,
what you're saying is you decentralize things.
You let people come up with new ideas and suddenly we will have a thinner can
and less resources will be taken and it'll actually be cheaper and there'll be
more readily available.
The answer to climate change is not going to come from central planning and from
restrictions for two reasons,
let's divide the world into two halves in one half,
you have rich people like you and I relatively rich, obviously,
um, living in democracies now we are prepared to
pay a little more for the protection of the environment we are.
And we are willing to put up with taxes, which are a little bit higher,
but not much higher. In fact, all the opinion, polls and, and, um,
surveys suggest that people are willing to put up a little more toward, uh,
toward cleaning of the climate.
What they are not prepared to do is to end the first world lifestyles as
they know it on, uh, for the benefit of, uh, of, of,
uh, environment or climate change, right?
Isn't that in essence, what was happening in France,
that they kept raising taxes on gas to do climate initiatives. And that,
that basically started riot. And then you've got the rights to she'll homie.
And, um, so, um, and so those,
this one half reach people in democracies will not vote to
end civilization full stop. Then you have the second half of the world, uh,
let's say very poor people or relatively poor people who live in countries,
which are not democracies, places like that.
Places like China and places like India, the governments,
there are not going to forego the possibility of rapid economic
growth and becoming rich,
just because people in rich countries demand that we shouldn't land it off
them because it is immoral.
And those governments are not going to do it because they are not suicidal.
Even China, which is a totalitarian and awful regime.
And which keeps saying we are going to go carbon free by this state and other
day, they are building a record number of, uh,
coal powered power plants. As we speak. In other words,
they understand that there is nothing
surer to destroy the communist parties hold on power than
denying the Chinese people a better life.
Yeah.
Is that sort of an offshoot of the rationale that got
us out of the Paris Accords that in essence,
these countries were going to keep doing these things because they had to do
them as they go through their industrial revolutions talking say about China and
India, while we were going to put regulations on ourselves and,
and pay for the brunt of it.
And there was no enforcement mechanism and everything else.
I said that it was a part of it is that there is the,
the United States right now.
I don't believe I haven't looked at those figures in a while,
but I don't think that the United States is the largest polluter in the world.
I think that China and India are above us. Now,
here you have four and a half billion people, um,
who are trying to get rich quick and who are spewing a lot of CO2 into the
atmosphere and who are also very competitive with us because they have very low
wages. So to tie ourselves to the Paris climate accord,
uh, was the wrong way to go about it. And you know,
what else happened was that the United States has decreased its
emissions of CO2 per capita at a faster pace than most places in the
world. Why? Because we started, uh,
we started getting rid of our coal power plants and we started introducing more
and more natural gas into our electricity production and natural gas
burns, or rather emits much less CO2 than coal.
And so by simply by innovating,
by basically changing the source of fuel from coal to natural gas,
we were able to decrease our CO2 emissions at a faster click than we would have
been obliged to do under Paris. Alright.
Right. So let's move on to trend number four.
I thought this was interesting because I see a lot of talk of this kind of thing
online related to peak population. And we're,
we're putting too many people on this earth. Is it true?
Eight is not true. Um,
right now there are 7.8 billion of us.
The global population will peak in about 20, 60, 20,
70 at roughly 909 and a half billion.
And then it will start declining. There are a number of studies done on this.
The latest one came from landset,
which is a very highly regarded British medical paper.
And what they have concluded is that by 2100,
there will be anywhere between 6.8 and 8.8 billion people in the world.
So roughly 1 billion, less than we have today, or 1 billion more.
I'm very ambivalent about this trend,
because I think that because humans are the only entities in the
world capable of actually producing ideas.
If you're going to come up with a cure for cancer,
if you're going to come up for a solution to climate change and fusion reactor,
you need the human brain to do that.
Artificial intelligence is simply not there yet. So fewer human beings,
we have the harder it will be to produce enough geniuses
to come up with ideas, to solve our problems. Nonetheless,
the reality is that the total fertility rate,
which is to say the number of babies that a woman can expect
to have in her life is now roughly around 2.4 or
replacement level is 2.1 replacement level basically means that
if you have fewer babies than that,
the global population starts declining in Europe,
in places like Czech Republic, where my ancestors are from or Slovakia.
Uh, the total fertility rate is 1.3, 1.4, rather than 2.1,
which is needed just to keep the population steady. And, um,
the only place really, which is above 2.1,
2.4 is Africa. Population of Africa is still going to increase for a while,
but globally we have fewer and fewer babies being born
per woman. Why is that?
Is because women are getting education and they are getting work.
What happens when a woman gets work,
is that the opportunity costs of staying at home and taking care of children
increases she can do with her life. Other things,
she can earn a lot of money in the marketplace.
And so she has fewer and fewer babies. This relationship, uh,
is we are seeing it no matter which continent, uh, you are looking at it,
we see it everywhere. And we expect that as Africa becomes richer,
African women will start having fewer and fewer babies below the replacement
level. Yeah.
Some of this stuff feels like it must be,
it must be hard to track because if you were to say, okay,
let's look a hundred years in the future.
And with the trends of how people are reproducing right now. Well,
all sorts of other trends change and changes and migration patterns change in
everything else. So that, that explains why it could be 1 billion over or under,
right?
Correct. It is also based on, uh, on,
on assumptions about economic growth and access to education.
We expect that the economy will continue to grow. I mean,
if the economy stops growing or if there is a de-growth in certain parts of the
world, uh,
then the relationship between increased wealth and fewer babies obviously ends.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversation about the
environment, instead of nonstop yelling, check out our environment playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.